j'aborde cette élection avec beaucoup de
sérénité les rencontres avec la
population démontre que cette population
à coeur de souffle nouveau de voir une
équipe renouvelée à la tête de la
municipalité
et c'est ce que nous voulons leur offrir
avec ducos s'engagent des hommes et des
femmes qui ont à coeur de mettre leurs
expériences leurs compétences leur
savoir au service de ducos de tous les
ducaux c'est vraiment travailler avec
l'ensemble des diocèses et c'est l'une
des raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle la
démocratie participative sera au coeur
de notre projet parce que nous voulons
associer au maximum à la fois le
personnel qui est le pilier de la
politique communale que nous voudrons
mettre en place et la population que
nous devons insatisfaits je me sens
complètement à l'aise au sein d'un pays
et au sein du paysage politique choix
que les femmes et les jeunes ont leur
place à prendre
bien sûr ça nécessite du travail il faut
travailler la confiance de la population
et je crois que c'est ce que nous
faisons en tout cas à ducos s'engage
c'est un travail quotidien c'est un
travail qui n'a pas commencé aujourd'hui
et j'espère que ces fouilles vont porter
en tout cas j'encourage tous ceux qui
ont envie de s'engager à le faire parce
que c'est important
il faut oser le pays a besoin de nous
notre commune a besoin de nous et je
crois vraiment que lorsqu'on a à coeur
d'être au service de l'autre il faut
foncer faut y aller prendre ses valeurs
et ne pas avoir peur